foreign
s
or specifically the problem with
capitalism but before we do that I want
to talk to you about this Instagram
account that I follow it's called humans
of capitalism and there's this image
Jordan I'm gonna have you find it and
put it on the screen and and
post-production here there is this
picture which I'll describe if you're
just listening to the audio version of
the podcast
it's a picture of desk chairs but they
are shaped like coffins so it's coffin
shaped desk chairs and wow I saw this
and what I think about when I see that
image is yeah many of us are doing
something where we're not really living
and if you're not really living then one
might say you're dying so you're not
literally dead there at the desk chair
but then I see the other side of it as a
writer I sit down every day and many of
the times I feel most alive is at a desk
chair so it's not binary it's not that
if you sit in a desk chair therefore you
are not living life but it is that oh
it's calling out the one of one of the
problems with capitalism is if I put
money first if I'm interested in value
extraction more than I am with value
creation those are two different types
of capitalism so only hand it to utk by
saying this
I think we need to talk about what is
capitalism because we can use capitalism
as a pejorative and when someone uses it
pejoratively what they're really talking
about I think is crony capitalism or the
use of people in order to make money
we've turned profit into our God value
extraction into our God the other side
of capitalism is this value creation or
what Ryan and you and I call adding
value to our audience or if you are a
big business you can still add value to
customers and we appreciate that when
people add value to our lives when I can
buy a product or service in a way that
is not coercive or manipulative and
you're providing that service for me
well that's the type of capitalism that
works but there's this other side and
it's an ugly side that really doesn't
work and I have a big problem with that
and I was hoping you could help me flesh
this out yeah you should have a big
problem with that so I prefer the term
voluntarism over capitalism because even
though there is a way to Define
capitalism that is perfectly consistent
with my economic philosophy the root of
the word capitalism is capital and so
when people think of capitalism it has
this negative connotation of meaning the
exaltation of prophets over people
pursuing Capital at the expense of
compassion creativity and Goodwill
towards other human beings and that is a
philosophy I disavow I do not support
any economic philosophy that says it's
all about the money and if you got the
chance to screw people over and do
unethical things in order to get a
little bit richer I want you to be able
to do those things absolutely not and in
some debates and discussions on
capitalism that word strikes me as being
hopelessly lost to that understanding
and so so sometimes it can be best to
just adopt the new vocabulary because
when people don't think they already
know what you're going to say there's a
higher probability that they'll actually
listen and they'll judge you on your
actual words rather than associations of
your words with someone that they know
they disagree with for me voluntarism or
rather positive capitalism which is
different from corporatism or crony
capitalism is any economic condition
that has three three elements number one
customer accountability that businesses
don't just get to profit independently
of their ability to satisfy customers
create value for them and solve problems
for them they can't hide behind
regulations and laws that allow them to
be profitable in spite of the fact that
their customers aren't happy with their
service to quote Milton Friedman he says
in a true free market you're not only
free to succeed but you're also free to
fail so if a business is not free to
fail because they're being artificially
insulated from customer accountability
by regulations then that's not truly
voluntaries freedom of competition can
someone else even the little guy enter
the market and at least try to compete
with you at providing the service that
you provide there are many larger
corporations that actually love
regulations because they can afford the
regulations they can set aside millions
of dollars in their budget every year to
hire lobbyists who do nothing more than
try to advocate for regulations that
sound good rhetorically but that
actually make it artificially difficult
for the little guy the small player to
come in and compete with them so
although the rhetoric of most
regulations it's almost always to
protect the little guy because you just
can't sell anything without that
rhetoric many of the biggest supporters
of those of that kind of rhetoric are
the big players that can afford all of
the legal fees and so on to make it hard
for people to compete with them the
third element is freedom of consumer
choice as a customer do I have to buy
your product no matter how much you
dissatisfy me or am I free to express my
dissatisfaction by saying you know what
I'm going to take my money elsewhere and
I'm going to pay this person who
actually treats me with respect or who
makes me feel valued if you can use the
power of law big guy big Corporation to
take those options away from me so that
no matter how angry I am well you're the
only provider in my geographical
location and I gotta pay you
and and you can hide behind the law well
then that's really not free right and
many people will say well that's
capitalism and I get what they mean
which is why I use the word voluntarism
I think more economic flourishing more
economic possibility and more
satisfaction is created when customers
have the ability to hold businesses
accountable to opt out and put their
money elsewhere and when the average
player has the ability to at least try
to compete no system is capable of
producing human Perfection but that is
the system that I believe that optimizes
for human flourishing let me ask you
something uh because this makes me think
let me ask you something brother
all right go ahead
leave the jokes to me TK
no so um when it what has me thinking of
is is uh monopolies so in an unchecked
capitalistic Market does that naturally
lead to monopolies
so the fear of Monopoly is one of the
most effective
persuasive tools against any kind of
voluntarious system and it's a
complicated argument what I want to say
here is that while monopolies are
possible
we shouldn't fool ourselves into
thinking that there is an economic
system that makes monopolies impossible
or even improbable what I mean by that
is there are real monopolies that exist
for no other reason than that big
powerful corporations are able to
establish regulatory hurdles that make
it incredibly difficult for anyone else
to enter the market and grow large
enough to be able to compete with them
one of the things that we see that's so
tragic is you know there used to be a
time where pulling yourself up by your
own bootstraps entrepreneurially were
was more possible than it is today and
one of the reasons why it's become
increasingly difficult is because there
are a number a number of regulations
that say hey in order to go into this
kind of business you got to have this
kind of training you got to have this
these conditions Matt you got to have
this kind of facility and it sounds good
on the surface right because if I'm
selling the business I say hey look man
don't you think that anybody who uh
braids hair or cuts hair should have a
barber shop where you can go to yeah
that sounds nice don't you think anybody
who is in the business of braiding hair
or cutting hair that they ought to meet
certain regulations like have at least
three chairs and and looking sound this
way like yeah this sounds really good
that's great
but now what happens to that person who
has about 20 customers they're not very
rich they have that person come over to
the apartment to get their hair braided
and they say hey I'm gonna have kids
running around the TV is going to be
loud and they're like no it's all good I
don't mind right they come over you're
putting that person in a position where
what they do is illegal and if they ever
want to get to a place where they
actually can do their business in a more
professional way they got to have a lot
more Capital to be able to get off the
ground you know and so none of these
things are perfect but I think the
notion of Monopoly often gets laid at
the feet of a system that lacks all of
the regulatory hurdles but sometimes
monopolies are supported by regulations
that are lobbied for by people who are
really powerful and are threatened by
creative people that have less power
than them yeah
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free